the 92nd emotional window Studies have
shown that within 90 seconds our bodies
can reset themselves back to a natural
state often what we can struggle with is
something will happen it's not the
actual thing that's caused us to sort of
exacerbate the situation it's our
response from it so you might have just
got off a call hensely you go I'm gonna
have a terrible day today so the idea
behind this is getting a stopwatch out
on your phone or your Smartwatch count
to 90 and then it's deciding what you do
after that so you might use that 90
second window and then go am I really
stressed what else could be true here am
I hungry am I tired before I jump to
that conclusion within 90 seconds you
can change your state so at the end it's
being able to put yourself into a
rational state so that you can then make
a logical decision at the end of 90
seconds right rather than jump straight
to I'm gonna have the worst day ever
today because your Primal brain is
driving